lo que vamos a hacer en este vídeo es
pensar en la posición de un objeto que
se mueve en una dimensión para hacer
esto vamos a ver algunos conceptos el
primero es el de desplazamiento y es
probable que usen esta palabra en su
lenguaje cotidiano literalmente
significa el cambio en la posición
un concepto relacionado que a veces se
confunde con el desplazamiento es la
distancia recorrida y quizás se
pregunten acaso no son lo mismo en un
momento veremos que no son lo mismo la
distancia recorrida es la longitud total
de una ruta de qué estamos hablando
vamos a introducir algo de cálculo
digamos que tenemos la función de la
velocidad de una partícula digamos que
nuestra velocidad como función del
tiempo es igual a 5 menos t muchas veces
cuando algo tiene sólo una dimensión las
personas se olvidan de que éstas también
pueden ser cantidades vectoriales esta
velocidad es una cantidad de vectorial
porque podemos pensar que si es positiva
se está moviendo a la derecha y si es
negativa se está moviendo a la izquierda
así que tiene una dirección a veces
veremos que una cantidad vectorial tiene
una flecha encima o estará resaltada en
negritas en lo personal me gusta poner
la flecha pero esta no siempre es la
convención gráfica moss esta función
velocidad ya lo hice y vemos que el
tiempo está en segundos y la velocidad
está en metros por segundo
escribimos las unidades cuando el tiempo
es cero nuestro
viaja a 5 metros por segundo y podemos
decir que se mueve a la derecha tiene
una velocidad de 5 metros por segundo
positivo después desacelera a una tasa
constante por lo que 5 segundos después
la partícula no tiene velocidad alguna y
después comienza a tener una velocidad
negativa que podemos decir se mueve a la
izquierda
pensemos en algunas cosas primero
pensemos en cuál es el desplazamiento
durante los primeros cinco segundos como
ya hemos visto varias veces si queremos
encontrar el cambio de cierta cantidad
debemos calcular la integral de la
gráfica de la velocidad por lo que la
velocidad es en realidad la razón del
desplazamiento para el desplazamiento
durante los primeros cinco segundos
calculamos la integral definida de 0 a 5
segundos de nuestra función velocidad
podemos calcular la rápidamente en esta
área de aquí que con un poco de
geometría podemos encontrar un triángulo
de 5 x 5 5 x 5 es 25 por un medio
recordemos la fórmula del área de un
triángulo un medio por base por altura
esto es igual a 12.5
por segundo por segundo nos dan metros
este es el cambio en la posición de esa
partícula durante los primeros cinco
segundos de donde sea que estaba en el
tiempo cero cinco segundos después está
a 12.5 metros a la derecha de ese lugar
recordemos que la cantidad positiva
indica que está a la derecha y que pasa
durante los primeros 10 segundos esto se
pone interesante y los invito a qué
pausa en el vídeo y piensen en esto cuál
será el desplazamiento de la partícula
durante los primeros diez segundos
hacemos lo mismo
calculamos la integral de 0 a 10 de
nuestra función velocidad en una
dimensión es el área que va desde este x
0 hasta este otro x igual a 10 pero
recuerden que cuando calculamos una
integral el área debajo del eje y por
arriba de la función se considera un
área negativa estas dos áreas se van a
cancelar y tendremos cero metros y quizá
ustedes se pregunten cómo puede ser esto
posible cómo es posible que después de
diez segundos nuestro desplazamiento
sean cero metros sí
no ha dejado de moverse durante todo ese
tiempo recordemos lo que está pasando
durante los primeros cinco segundos la
partícula se mueve a la derecha
desacelerando todo el tiempo justo a los
cinco segundos se ha movido 12.5 metros
a la derecha después su velocidad
comienza a ser negativa y la partícula
comienza a moverse a la izquierda
durante los últimos cinco segundos la
partícula se mueve 12.5 metros a la
izquierda por lo que estas dos cosas se
cancelan entre sí en 10 segundos la
partícula se movió 12.5 metros a la
derecha y después 12.5 metros a la
izquierda por lo que su cambio en
posición es de 0 metros no ha cambiado
la posición ahora comenzarán a apreciar
la diferencia entre desplazamiento y
distancia con la distancia vemos la
longitud total de la ruta recorrida no
nos interesa la dirección del movimiento
así que en lugar de pensar en la
velocidad lo que haremos es pensar en la
rapidez en este caso y en especial en
una dimensión la rapidez es igual al
valor absoluto de la velocidad más
cuando veamos múltiples dimensiones esta
será la magnitud de la función velocidad
que es el valor absoluto de la función
en una dimensión como se verá esto
xilográfica mos el valor absoluto de la
función velocidad luce así si queremos
conocer la distancia recorrida vamos a
calcular la integral durante el cambio
en el tiempo apropiado de la función
rapidez que es lo que grafica mos aquí
si queremos conocer la distancia
recorrida durante los primeros cinco
segundos vamos a calcular la integral de
0 a 5 del valor absoluto de nuestra
función velocidad que podemos ver como
nuestra función rapidez es esta área que
ya sabemos es igual a 12.5 metros
durante los primeros 5 segundos la
rapidez y la velocidad son iguales ya
que en este caso la función velocidad es
positiva durante este intervalo por lo
que su valor absoluto también será
positivo pero si vemos la distancia
recorrida durante los primeros diez
segundos cuál será pausa en el vídeo y
traten de calcularla por su cuenta
va a ser la integral de 0 a 10 del valor
absoluto de la función velocidad con
al tiempo a que será igual será esta
área más esta otra área es igual a 5 por
5 por un medio más 5 por 5 por un medio
que será igual a 25 metros la partícula
se ha movido 12.5 metros a la derecha y
después otros 12.5 metros a la izquierda
el desplazamiento o cambio neto de la
posición es igual a 0 mientras que la
longitud total de la ruta recorrida es
de 25 metros y con esto terminamos